welcome to the David Pacman show I'm
Farren cousins once again sitting in for
David packman we've got a wonderful show
coming up today gotta talk a little bit
about the January 6 committee more news
on Joe manchin and of course Donald
Trump and Bill O'Reilly's History tour
where Trump got in a bit of trouble with
his audience for admitting he had been
vaccinated so let's Jump Right In let's
start actually with Donald Trump and
Bill O'Reilly uh during their History
tour that was in Texas this past weekend
Bill O'Reilly talked to Donald Trump
about the vaccines and Trump encouraged
the crowd
take credit for it don't miss this
opportunity but it was when
Bill O'Reilly admitted he had been
vaccinated and then Trump admitted he
had been vaccinated and boosted
that the crowd turned against them here
it is take a look at this entire clip of
what happened
but look we did something that was
historic we saved tens of millions of
lives worldwide we together all of us
not me we we got a vaccine done three
vaccines done and tremendous
Therapeutics like regeneron and other
things that have saved a lot of lives
we got a vaccine done in less than nine
months it was supposed to take from five
to 12 years because of that vaccine
because of that vaccine millions and
millions of people I think this would
have been the Spanish Flu of 1917 where
up to a hundred million people died this
was going to ravage the country far
beyond what it is right now
take credit for it take credit for it's
a great what we've done is historic
don't let them take away don't take it
away from ourselves you're playing that
you're playing right into their hands
when you sort of like oh the vaccine if
you don't want to take it you shouldn't
be forced to take it no mandates but
take credit because we saved tens of
millions of lives take credit don't let
them take that away from you okay so the
president made news you agree with that
right
both the president and I are vacs and uh
did you get the booster
yes I got it too okay so um
that's a very tiny group of it all right
so they've both gotten their booster
shots
and
the audience wasn't too thrilled with
that but as Trump said don't worry it's
just a small group of people over here
all right here's the thing most of what
Trump said there
I'm okay with right
actually encouraging people like you
should get the vaccine and then of
course he undoes it by saying but if you
don't want to get it you shouldn't be
forced to no mandates okay see you kind
of lost it there but I understand you
got to play to your base
but think about this and I I've actually
mentioned this all throughout this year
when vaccines became readily available
you didn't have to get on waiting lists
yet there's still so much hesitancy
within the Republican Party itself
Trump could have been doing this months
ago with these exact same talking points
right coming out saying listen trust it
I have mine
this was developed while I was President
you guys love me right so if you love me
get yourself vaccinated and then of
course he could have done the same thing
once boosters became recommended
but he didn't
in fact you could tell from that clip
right there he wasn't even sure that he
wanted to admit that he got the booster
shot
because he was cut he was just like yes
and then of course he immediately had to
go on the defensive like no no no don't
do that don't do this small group of
people over here
if you had owned this from the beginning
again I don't even care if you took
credit for things that weren't even
yours if it meant people getting
vaccinated getting the country maybe
back to normal stopping the death and
destruction the virus is causing I would
have been okay with that
there's a lot of lies obviously that
Trump has told over the years that I'm
really not happy about that I dislike
and I've spent hours refuting them on my
shows even on this show here
but taking credit for the vaccine sure
whatever whatever it takes at this point
to get conservatives vaccinated to get
them boosted and of course the remainder
of the the Democrats and everybody else
out there
We're All in This Together
okay we we have to come together here
and believe it or not for most of what
Trump was saying there
it almost appears that that's what he
was trying to do
now we know he wasn't pulling one of
those everybody's got to come together
and defeat this moment he was trying to
take credit for what's happening today
he's trying to take credit for the fact
that people are getting vaccinated
does he deserve credit for that no
probably not
but again I'm okay if he tries to usurp
some of the credit if it means getting
more people vaccinated
right now
in Trump counties counties in the
country that voted for Donald Trump
which I'm sure we all know by now
the death rate is three times higher
from covid than the counties that voted
for Joe Biden
conservatives
are dropping dead from covid at a far
greater rate than Liberals are
that that's what that means that's what
the science is telling us
and for these Republicans out there
to take the opposite approach which
we're actually going to talk about that
in just a moment
but Trump understands I think maybe to a
degree
that you can't kill your base I think
Bill O'Reilly to a degree again
understands that
I think some of the people at Fox News
understand that
you can't continue to let these people
die
and still expect your conservative
Outlet or your conservative cause or
your conservative campaign
to be successful you know here in the
State of Florida and I always like to
use this as an example elections
at least at the state level the last
presidential election was not as close
they're very close typically decided
within a few thousand or a couple ten
thousand votes
well we've had 62 000 people die of
covet here in the State of Florida and
again the numbers are going back up all
over the country
they're Rising almost faster than
anywhere else in the country here in the
state of Florida
and again it is affecting
Republicans more than it is affecting
Democrats because according to the
numbers they're far less likely to have
been vaccinated and boosted than the
Democrats
so you're killing your base
in a state down here in Florida
that could be decided the next
governor's race in 2022 could be decided
by ten thousand twenty thousand votes
well you've sent that many conservatives
more than that to their graves
so how are these people not waking up
and understanding that this isn't a
winning electoral strategy you know
forget the economic impacts forget the
human right the empathy aspect of it all
think of it from a purely political
standpoint what do you have to gain
from your base dying
before the next election
we all know the answer to that we know
that you have nothing to gain
you're not going to win political favor
from people who are dead
and again I think at least to a small
degree
Trump understood that
and of course he wants all the credit
he wants the pandemic to end just as
much as everybody else but he wants it
to end
so that he can say my Administration is
really the one that ended it we put the
vaccines on The Fast Track we got this
done we gave the money to Big Pharma
they did this in nine months instead of
five to ten years which yes is the
typical timetable for getting a vaccine
ready and approved and out there to the
public he's right about that believe it
or not
but it is a selfish reason
but at this point
we may have to accept a little bit of
selfishness
from these individuals if it means they
get vaccinated right
we can do the fact checking later we can
correct the misinformation about who did
what with the vaccines at a later date
once everybody is protected
once we finally for real for good
flattened the curve then we can have
those discussions in the meantime
if what it takes is letting Trump go out
there and try to take credit for the
vaccine in order to get conservatives to
take it I am okay with that and I think
a lot of people also should be okay with
this
it doesn't matter
which party is or isn't getting the
vaccine when you still have such a large
part of the population that hasn't even
gotten a single dose yet that's a
problem
it's going to allow for more mutations
more infections more overcrowded
hospitals
and more deaths
so at this point we are in what I
consider to be a whatever it takes
scenario
so if it means Trump hogging some credit
for the next few months in order to get
these conservatives vaccinated
believe it or not
I'm okay with that
but as I mentioned
there's the opposite side of the
spectrum that appears to be far too
prevalent within the Republican Party
and those of course are the individuals
who say don't get vaccinated don't trust
the vaccines
there's more of us than there are of
them and of course those are the talking
points that came out of Sarah Palin at
the Turning Point USA conference this
past weekend
in fact Palin went as far as to say that
she'll get the vaccine over her dead
body
which you you may have wanted to choose
your words a little more carefully there
because we've seen what this virus does
800 000 Americans dead saying Over My
Dead Body
probably not the best choice of words
there so let me read you
what Palin had to say during her little
q a at the TP USA conference
we were led to believe that we wouldn't
have to have the shot well then they
changed their tune and now those of us
who have had covid they're telling us
that even though we've had it and we
have natural immunity now that we still
have to get a shot it will be over my
dead body
that I'll have to get a shot I will not
do it
again
probably not a good choice of words
there and of course before I go into
what else she said natural immunity does
not provide you the same level of
protection as the vaccines
the studies have already shown that yes
natural immunity can provide you some
protection from it absolutely
but it doesn't give you as much
protection as the vaccines so let's
dispel without talking point right off
the bat
but let's continue because this is where
things get weird this is where she
differs from Trump you know Trump said
oh you you should get it but if you
don't want to you don't have to Palin
actively encouraged people to straight
up not take it at all here's what she
says
there are more of us than there are of
them
you need to all look around and realize
as you stiffen your spine and take those
positions and we know our rights
especially when it comes to the
government telling us what we have to
inject in our own bodies realize that
those around you as you stiffen your
spine their spines will stiffen too
is spine stiffening a symptom of covid
because if it is then I think she's spot
on there
but what she said there's more of us
than there are of you first of all no
there's not there's actually more
vaccinated people in this country than
there are unvaccinated people
so right off the bat you're wrong if
that is in fact what you're talking
about
again this is Sarah Palin though so we
really don't know exactly what she's
trying to say or what she might mean
because that's how Sarah Palin operates
but if you're like me the biggest shock
out of what Sarah Palin said here
was the fact that she was even at the
Turning Point USA conference to begin
with
right at what point did Sarah Palin
become relevant again
don't they have enough right-wing nut
jobs out there to fill that role now
that they don't have to go tap the Well
from the person who hasn't been relevant
since 2008 that's a little weird to me
right nobody even thinks about Sarah
Palin anymore
kind of like Ann Coulter and Coulter
reemerges twice a year with a horrible
talking point and then just disappears
for like six months
Sarah Palin's been irrelevant since 08
though
so I don't know why Turning Point said
you know who would be a good speaker
here
Sarah Palin
maybe somebody got fired for that
decision I don't know
but I gotta tell you it's a little bit
weird because she's not exactly a
newsmaker these days and certainly not a
major player at all in Republican
politics and probably won't continue to
be one
if she's encouraging her base to do
things that could get them killed
I'm Farren cousins you can follow me on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram at fair
and balanced we'll be right back with
more of the David packman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
welcome back to the David packman show
I'm Faron cousins from Ring of Fire I'll
be sitting in for David all of this week
and if by chance you want more from me
you can find me on YouTube at
youtube.com
fahrenbalanced and of course youtube.com
the Ring of Fire
one of the biggest stories that is still
happening this week is more and more new
information continues to trickle out
every couple hours honestly at this
point is Joe manchin
the biggest baddest bad guy in the
country today Joe manchin
and on Monday The Huffington Post
reported that Joe manchin has allegedly
according to two Insiders
that Huffington Post spoke to
Mansion has been telling his Democratic
colleagues
then one of the main reasons he is
objecting to extending the child tax
credit that has lifted 30 percent of
children in this country out of poverty
is because if you give poor people money
they're just going to spend it on drugs
now there's no audio at least not that
I've seen or has been reported on of Joe
manchin saying these things so let's you
know mention that right off the bat this
is coming from two insiders who spoke to
the Huffington Post they said this is
what Mansion has been telling people
behind the scenes this is his talking
point if you give poor people money
they're gonna spend it on drugs
so
we have to assume at the moment or at
least for the sake of this segment here
we're going to assume what they're
saying is accurate again without a
recording of this without it written
down Joe manchin writing it himself
we can't say for certain that Joe
manchin did say this so let's imagine
that he did okay
let's imagine for a moment that Joe
manchin used this tired worn out
Republican talking point
to trash the extended child tax credit
which again Has Lifted 30 percent of
children in this country out of poverty
30 percent
this child tax credit that's been going
out for most of this year has
fundamentally changed the lives of
millions of Americans
but it has become one of Joe manchin's
biggest Targets in the build back better
bill
and is it really because he honestly
thinks that poor people if they get cash
in hand they're just gonna buy drugs is
that really what he believes
does he honestly think that every poor
person in this country everybody living
in poverty is just on drugs
is that
what he thinks the cause of poverty and
suffering is here in the United States
it's only because of drugs
if somebody is living in poverty
that in no way makes them more likely to
do drugs here in the United States
poverty is not a manifestation
that comes from addiction
and it's absolutely
embarrassing and irresponsible
for anyone left or right to make that
claim
and if this is in fact how Joe manchin
feels if he did really say this
to his Democratic colleagues which I
would love if any one of them would come
forward and say Yes Mansion told me this
let's confirm it
so if this did happen
I believe at this point the Democratic
party would have no choice but to kick
Joe manchin out
and I believe that they should I believe
they should kick him off of his
committees
I believe that they should
refuse to give him any funding from the
party
not just based on this statement either
by the way
based on the fact that he is obstructing
the democrat's own agenda
you know Bernie Sanders pointed out last
week in an interview with Chris Hayes on
MSNBC that mansion and Cinema were
acting like Republicans
and when you look at what Republicans
have done this year
nothing but obstruction
obstruct obstruct obstruct especially in
the Senate
but then when you look at mansion and
Cinema
obstruct obstruct obstruct
so it is as if they were acting like
Republicans not as if they are
that is what this is Joe manchin
understands what buildback better could
do
to residents of West Virginia they're
not happy with him by the way
the story's been pouring in ever since
his appearance on Fox news on Sunday
about West Virginia residents unhappy
that Joe manchin is standing in the way
of this
but it all comes down at the moment to
that child tax credit
you know last week Mansion uh was
confronted by reporters asking why do
you oppose the child tax credit he said
it was BS your BS this isn't true I
never said that I never did that but I
think it was October 21st
is when the news reports came out saying
that Joe manchin wants to cut down the
child tax credit wants to put a cap on
it you know if you make over 60 000 a
year you don't get anything at all so he
wanted to lower the cap that was
reported back then he didn't call those
reports BS
so he's lying
he's lying to us he's lying to his
constituents he's lying to the country
about what he actually is trying to do
and again if this Huffington Post report
is accurate and again we cannot say for
certain that it happened
but if this report is accurate
then he is basing his rationale for
killing the extended child tax credit
on faulty and fraudulent information
and that is unacceptable considering how
much this bill would benefit the
American public
it's not going to lead to inflation it's
not going to lead to expanded drug use
here in the United States
it would help continue to lift people
out of poverty
it would help people be able to afford
their bills
it would help people have a way a
stepping stone
to creating a better life that is what
this piece of legislation would do build
back better
it is literally right there in the name
folks
but Joe manchin doesn't think you should
have it
because Joe manchin thinks you're going
to go buy drugs
absolutely sickening
that this sitting Democratic member of
the United States Senate
would result to Republican talking
points going all the way back by the way
to Ronald Reagan
right the welfare Queens
the people living high on the government
hog
while the rest of you hard-working folks
are out there working your fingers to
the Bone
but they're getting the free government
money not having to do anything
that's what this is this is a
continuation
of the fraudulent Welfare Queen Trope
pushed by Republicans in the 80s and of
course ever since then
not to mention the fact you know just
based on statistics
we know that means testing and of course
drug testing
welfare recipients government assistance
recipients
yields very little results in fact from
2011 to 2017
you had multiple States across the
country enact some kind of drug testing
in order to receive social welfare
programs
one percent one percent
of the applicants who were tested tested
positive for drugs one percent
over a six-year period
so that alone kills Joe manchin's
talking point
helps kill that age-old Republican
talking point too
but apparently that wasn't enough it
didn't stop Joe manchin from allegedly
telling his colleagues
that if you give poor people more money
they're just going to go spend it on
drugs
now as I mentioned
Joe manchin of course is Public Enemy
Number One right now but at the same
time
we also have to remember that there's
also 50 Republicans in that Senate body
and all 50 of those Republicans
including those moderates
moderates and quotes there
all 50 of them are against this piece of
legislation too
so let's take just a moment and give
them the credit that they are due
because after all let's be real honest
here the media including those of us in
Progressive media we have focused a lot
of energy this year on Mansion Cinema
tester but really we also have to give
some of that blame to all 50 Republicans
in the Senate
because not a single one of them
not murkowski not Collins not Romney not
those sensible reasonable moderate
Republicans
none of them support this thing either
and at this point all it would take is
one
literally one because if we don't have
Joe manchin assuming we do have Cinema
in the other moderate Dems
if we got one Republican okay problem
solved
problem solved
but we can't even get one
and that also needs to be a bigger
talking point too
because Mansion has many years before he
is up for re-election and I promise you
by then the public will have forgotten
about this that's the way the news cycle
goes uh as the old saying goes the
public doesn't have a memory passed last
Tuesday
Cinema on the other hand
facing a re-election
fairly soon and things are not looking
good for her according to the polls
but
we have to make this a campaign issue
for the Republicans as well and that of
course lies with the Democratic Party
because everybody's been focusing on the
Democrats there they also have to
reshift some of the blame and put it
back on these Republicans
we're all well aware of Joe manchin's
role in all of this and of course by the
way uh Mansion of the White House have
said hey talks aren't over yet we're
going to keep talking about this so as I
actually pointed out yesterday on the
show when Mansion set on Fox News I
can't support this bill it likely means
this incarnation of the bill
but all those Republicans are against it
it wouldn't matter if you cut it down to
giving every American a single dollar
every one of those Republicans would
vote against it
because they know that build back better
even in its scaled down form
would still be a huge benefit to the
American public and therefore a huge
victory for Democrats to ride into the
midterms
so we have to dispel with the myth
that there are moderate Republicans out
there
and that's what Democrats need to attack
we've heard all the stories about the
Republican infighting you know oh
Trump's going after McConnell you've got
members of the House going after members
of the Senate
there's fighting they can't agree on
anything but no at the end of the day
they always come together
to do what's not best for the American
public
and the Democrats have to hammer on that
Republicans have 20 Senate seats up for
re-election
in the year 2022 so less than 12 months
away 20 of those Republicans have to
defend those seats
it's going to cost them a lot of money
to do this
it's very difficult for a party to not
only retain every single one of their
seats when they have more seats up but
also to win new ones
so Democrats have a shot in making some
inroads in the Senate here
of course it's going to be hard when
they don't have the thing to deliver to
the public so what you deliver instead
is the talking point that we would have
this
if you had one decent Republican in that
Senate body
because right now we don't
it doesn't matter if you're an extremist
if you're a hardcore corporatist like
Mitch McConnell or if you're the
seemingly sweet nice guy moderate and
Mitch uh not Mitch uh Mitt Romney
they're all the same at the end of the
day they're all fighting against this
agenda for political reasons only
and if the Democrats can hammer on that
if the Democrats can make that the
talking point if they can kind of shift
some Focus away from Joe manchin
who again I still agree he is the
biggest villain in all of this if it
weren't for him we wouldn't be having
this conversation
but we cannot let these 50 Republicans
get away without any of the blame
because all it would take is one
but we can't even get that to happen
I'm Farren cousins follow me on Twitter
YouTube
Instagram Facebook at farrenbalanced and
of course the big YouTube channel
youtube.com the ring of fire and if
that's not enough for you I also host
the weekly Ring of Fire podcast just go
to
rofpodcast.com to sign up I'm sitting in
for David packman we'll be right back
with more
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show welcome
back to the David packman show I'm
Farren cousins sitting in for David
packman this week let's get right back
to more news and uh what happened on
Monday
was it was revealed that Donald Trump is
suing
New York attorney general Leticia James
to get the investigation into his
company shut down
Trump's lawyers in their filing
argued quote
the lawsuit
was politically motivated
and the mission is guided solely by
political animus and a desire to harass
intimidate and retaliate against a
private citizen who she views as a
political opponent she of course being
New York attorney general Leticia James
this is without a doubt in my non-lawyer
expert opinion one of the dumbest legal
arguments I've honestly ever seen
this investigation has already resulted
in criminal charges criminal charges
against both the Trump organization
for tax crimes
and CFO Alan weisselberg
so how on Earth
are you going to go to court
in front of a judge and say judge listen
up
you know this investigation that is
going to put our CFO in jail and causing
us some legal headaches with the
organization well it's politically
motivated
the judge is going to look at that and
say but but there's there's criminal
charges like it's
it it's bore fruit
right we we have actual results
from this criminal investigation that
show Criminal wrongdoing so how are you
going to sit there and tell me that this
is a Witch Hunt when we've found witches
you know I mentioned this
over on my channel fair and balanced
um Donald Trump might actually have a
pretty good case for legal malpractice
at this point that's how bad this
argument is
now here's the thing
if this investigation which of course
has been going on for about two years
if it was going on for two years
and they couldn't find any evidence of
criminal wrongdoing you may have a very
slim chance of being successful with
this particular argument right you know
if you're looking at something for two
years and still can't find anything at
all you've poured through the documents
you've had the depositions and you have
nothing
then that's a good sign most likely that
there's nothing there
but there is a there there's there's a
there there
and there is that there have been
criminal charges on tax related uh uh
I guess you would call them activities
so you can't say that this is purely a
political motivated stunt
when you got a guy that's probably going
to jail for this
so the question comes down to timing
right
why at any point in the past two years
Donald Trump could have filed this
ridiculous lawsuit and said you're
coming after me because I'm president
you're a Democrat you hate me and blah
blah blah
he could have filed the lawsuit after
the charges were filed against CFO Alan
weisselberg and of course the Trump
organization itself was also indicted
but he didn't
he waited till now
so
now we get to put on our Speculator
glasses
and try to figure out why
my best guess and again this is just my
hypothesis
is that there's something big coming
down the pipeline
why wait till now
probably because you know something
As We Know
they've gotten a hold of Donald Trump's
financial documents
we have seen that this investigation
seems to span beyond the state of New
York at the moment you know there's
incidents in Chicago that are now also
being reviewed you've got some actually
also happening up in Rochester New York
all of it's centering around the same
thing did Trump and his organization
lie about the value of their properties
to both tax authorities and the banks
was it tax fraud or was it bank fraud or
maybe was it a little bit of both
that's what they're looking at up in
Westchester
that's what they're looking at over in
Chicago and that's what they're looking
at in New York
bunch of different trump-owned
properties
that are all being investigated for the
same thing and with what's happening in
Westchester for the record
um
they've got the proof
they've got his presidential filings
where he showed the property was worth
one thing and they've got the local tax
records where he claim it's worth
something far less than what he claimed
on his Financial disclosure forms
so maybe that's what it is
maybe the walls are closing in a little
too quickly for him maybe there's too
many investigations going on and he's
doing what he can to file this
ridiculous lawsuit
to maybe stall it a little bit
because at best that's all he's going to
do this is not going to get this lawsuit
thrown out of court but it may slow it
down a bit it may allow for a little bit
of appeal here and there it's going to
get tossed out of every cord it goes in
front of that's a given again because
the argument is very stupid
but it may be just enough for Trump
to delay it enough to maybe come up with
a decent legal argument for when things
finally go totally sideways
and speaking of Investigations what's
happening over in the state of Texas
Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton on
Trump's orders
has been investigating voter fraud in
the state of Texas right even though
Trump handily won the state of Texas he
still wanted an audit of some of the
areas that Joe Biden won much like he's
wanted here in the State of Florida and
I'll get more to that in just a moment
but in Texas they finally caved and said
all right all right we're going to
investigate because you want us to
investigate
and it was recently announced that Ken
Paxton's office spent 2.2 million
dollars this year investigating voter
fraud
twenty thousand lawyer hours
investigating voter fraud
and the state managed to close three
cases
in 2021
2.2 million dollars
three cases
20
000 hours of work
that's what Texas was able to do this
year and it's actually quite remarkable
because last year Texas closed 17 cases
related to voter fraud
so that would seem to indicate to me
that since there were fewer this year
obviously the 2020 election in Texas was
far more secure than their previous
election the midterm elections in 2018.
three cases that's it
you're talking about a little over seven
hundred thousand dollars per case
nearly 7 000 hours per case
is what the state of Texas spent in
terms of time and money to close these
three cases
the fact of the matter is that voter
fraud is not common in the United States
and it sure as heck has never been
common enough
to overthrow the results of an election
to overturn the election to swing an
election one way or the other
but Trump is still so just bent on
trying to prove that even in the areas
Biden won in a state that Trump won by a
lot
that somehow it still wasn't that much
Trump can't stand losing anything any
County no matter how blue it is
he still wants it to be read
because any person in this country
voting for Joe Biden instead of Donald
Trump is an affront to Donald Trump
and unfortunately we have these
Republican Governors out there like Greg
Abbott in Texas and of course Ron
DeSantis over here in Florida who are
more than willing to spend whatever it
takes
to make a mockery of their entire State
even though they've both assured us that
hey things are totally cool here we
didn't have any fraud
when Trump asks him to do something
they're danks are going to do it
even if it means spending twenty
thousand hours and 2.2 million dollars
to close three cases of possible voter
fraud let's let's remember that's
closing three cases
that doesn't mean three people were
found to have committed voter fraud it
means those three cases are over with
either they found the evidence and they
charged the individuals or they couldn't
find any evidence
and they just ended it
this report doesn't say which was which
we do know there's at least one case
that they did find
but the other two
may have been completely wasted
all the money thousands of hours of
people's work
for absolutely nothing
but not to be outdone folks as I
mentioned Florida trying to give in to
Trump's crazy demands too and our Trump
loving Governor Ron DeSantis over here
in Florida
is asking the state legislature to give
him
5.2 million dollars
so that he can create an office of
election crime and security next year
now he is urging the state legislature
to give him this new office
when they resume their session next year
obviously it's not going to happen in
2021 unfortunately for him
but again Trump has demanded that we do
some audits here in Florida only of the
areas Biden won the five counties Biden
won in South Florida the big ones
um and Ronda Santa says sure let me go
talk to the legislature I just got to
get about five million dollars I gotta
hire roughly 50 people
so you know it's going to be good it's
gonna be a job creating thing right
we're gonna have a new Florida agency 49
permanent staffers
whose sole focus is going to be looking
into voter fraud
yeah I imagine there's going to be some
down time at that office so hey if
you're in the State of Florida looking
for a job where you don't really have to
do much maybe wait and see if this new
office gets created because that would
be the job for you
because the problem we have here is that
actually there is voter fraud in Florida
we found three cases
just last week it was revealed
all three of them from the retirement
community and called The Villages
and all three of them Republicans
see this is why
Trump and DeSantis and Abbott over in
Texas this is why you all got to be
careful what you wish for the vast
majority of the voter fraud cases that
have been found from the 2020 election
have been Republicans voting twice
obviously some of the more notable cases
we have the man who voted for his
deceased mother
used her ballot voted for Trump man who
voted for his deceased wife used her
ballot to vote for Trump the three
people down in The Villages that it was
revealed last week they voted here in
the State of Florida they also voted
absentee from other states
it didn't say who they voted for but
their all registered Republicans so we
don't have to
really even use our imaginations to
wonder how those votes went
and according to new reports they think
there's even more voter fraud that took
place in The Villages which is
predominantly Republican
so Ron DeSantis I'm going to tell you
this man I am actually okay with you
creating this Division I truly am
because voter fraud does need to be
addressed if it exists
and if you want to devote time and
resources to it then dang it you better
find some voter fraud here in the state
of Florida
and according to the reports according
to an ongoing investigation apparently
the first place you need to go are those
retirement communities where it is
predominantly Republicans
because that seems to be where the fraud
is running rampant
much like the other things that have
been running rampant in The Villages if
you don't know what I'm getting at I
suggest you Google it it is at one point
at least one of the highest rates of
STDs in the country but when they're not
doing that apparently some of them are
committing voter fraud as well and
that's what we're dealing with here in
the state of Florida
but let's not pretend for a second that
voter fraud is actually a real problem
that we need to be devoting millions and
millions and millions of dollars and
thousands and thousands and thousands of
hours towards fixing
are there cases out there heck yeah we
found plenty this year I mean we found a
couple handful of them let's be real
most of them were Republican
so if you all want to root it out
if you want to put your own people in
jail fine by me
I'm not going to stop you
but if you want to pretend that our
elections are somehow unsafe because of
all the fraud that's where I draw the
line because the evidence tells us
otherwise
I'm Farren cousins you can get me on
Twitter Facebook Instagram at fair and
balanced youtube.com the ring of fire
rofpodcast.com we'll be right back with
more
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
welcome back to the David packman show I
am Faron cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David packman this week
and if you've enjoyed me feel free
please subscribe to the ring of fire
podcast go to rofpodcast.com And
subscribe to our YouTube channel at
youtube.com the ring of fire or
youtube.com fahrenbalanced
let's get right back into the news we've
got a lot of Republican infighting and
of course some more news from the
January 6 Select Committee so let's jump
in first and foremost Steve Bannon
Steve Bannon is unhappy with Mitch
McConnell because Donald Trump is
unhappy with Mitch McConnell as we all
know Donald Trump has been engaged in a
months-long battle with Mitch McConnell
that has kind of had some highs and some
lows and Trump trying out his new
nickname for him the old broken Crow the
old crow the broken Old Crow a lot of
different iterations he hasn't quite
settled on one yet but either way he's
mad at Mitch McConnell and of course he
is encouraging Republicans to oust him
from his leadership position
so this past Friday on his war room show
Steve Bannon joined in and attacked
Mitch McConnell for what he sees as a
betrayal
of Donald Trump
here's what Bannon said
he is a direct challenge to president
Trump and Trump is trying to lead this
country through these horrible times
Mitch McConnell that dirt bag right
there gave the Biden regime two and a
half trillion to fund their Madness
their Madness
these are horrible times he says
and we're funding Madness
huh
you know what really gets me about that
before I get into the really the heart
of the argument here is what the hell
are they talking about horrible times
like what exactly are conservatives so
mad about right now other than losing
the 2020 election what about their lives
has changed
since Joe Biden came along right we
haven't had lockdowns
we we have vaccines readily available
we're on the verge of approving an
actual coveted treatment so you can't
complain about the covet stuff
he hasn't changed your taxes so you
can't complain about that so what
exactly
are conservatives angry about with the
Biden Administration honest to God I
want an answer to that I want a real
legitimate answer
from conservatives about what you're so
mad about from this Administration and I
think that is a question we should be
asking of them on a regular basis why
are you mad what has he done that makes
these horrible times
conversation for another day though
right folks let's get back to what Steve
Bannon said
he's betrayed Donald Trump he said
and this is because of course
they uh
work the deal out McConnell and Chuck
Schumer
to allow for the debt ceiling to be
raised that's what that's the heart of
all of this at least Steve bannon's
gripe
so we got a higher debt ceiling right so
the U.S doesn't default on their debt
and according to Bannon that's a
betrayal of trump
trail of trump
you know the old retired guy who's
sitting down there in Florida playing
golf he has been betrayed
he he's not in power Steve
so I don't know exactly what you're so
mad about betraying Donald Trump
because the man doesn't have a job he's
he's retired
but again Mitch McConnell Donald Trump
and now of course Steve Bannon been in
this Feud
Trump is trying to back uh Republicans
for Senate two of them have pledged if I
get in the office I'm going to kick
McConnell out of his leadership position
Trump is encouraging other Republicans
to do it and so far not a single sitting
Republican has signed on to this idea of
kicking Mitch McConnell out of his
leadership position let me explain why
but to explain why I got to read a
little bit more about what Bannon said
here
here's what your legacy will be people
are going to throw up in their mouth you
have betrayed the Republican Party
you've betrayed the movement you're only
there because of trump you never had any
loyalty
the man
who's been representing the people
of Kentucky in the United States Senate
since I was two years old
so since the 1980s the early 1980s
he's only there because of trump Steve
no
you've said a lot of dumb things in your
life and that might actually be one of
the dumbest
Mitch McConnell doesn't owe any of his
success and let's be honest it has been
a success for him to Donald Trump
like literally none of it
Mitch McConnell's Legacy is not going to
be people throwing up in their mouths
unless of course they're on the left
because his legacy is packing the courts
with these corporatist judges
his legacy is tax cuts for the wealthy
his legacy is obstructing any kind of
forward progress for the United States
of America
none of which he owes to Donald Trump
he did it under Reagan he did it under
H.W bush
he did it under George W bush
it wouldn't matter who the Republican
president was Mitch McConnell was one of
the guys calling the shots the entire
time
and when he had democratic presidents
Clinton Obama and now Biden he's been
leading the charge for obstruction none
of which again he owes to Donald Trump
so Ben and you're delusional if you
think that Mitch McConnell owes anything
to Donald Trump if anything it's the
other way around
Mitch McConnell is good at politics and
I will give him credit for that he is a
horrible person in my opinion who has
enacted some horrible policies and
blocked some great ones
but when it comes to being a republican
who knows how to do things Mitch
McConnell there's no one better than him
and that is literally the only praise I
will ever give for Mitch McConnell but
Steve Bannon has more problems than just
Mitch McConnell
because Roger Stone
Steve bannon's longtime Ally turned foe
has now once again gone after Steve
Bannon
this past week Roger Stone attempted to
throw Steve Bannon onto the bus with
regards to the January 6th Insurrection
by suggesting via his telegram account
that Steve Bannon may have been the one
that caused the capital riot
here's what he said
it is highly likely that Steve Bannon
really gave the order to breach the
capital and maneuvered Patriots into
dangerous positions a neophyte Steve
Bannon was willing to try crazy things
like this to Curry favor with Trump who
had a no interest that's how he wrote it
in bannon's BS
so more Republican infighting
now this is an interesting accusation
from Roger Stone who of course was
thrown under the bus by Steve Bannon
himself during Stone's criminal trial
Bannon testified against him so uh Stone
has had some bad blood against Bannon
ever since that happened but of course
Donald Trump gave him his presidential
pardon so these two weirdos I guess are
fighting over who gets to be Donald
Trump's right hand man
is it going to be Roger Stone
or is it going to be Steve Bannon
well Roger Stone's not going to pull any
punches here he is actually trying to
say that Steve Bannon is the one who
incited the capital Riot now that's a
strong accusation right
now Roger if you've got evidence to back
this up please do come forward with it
I know you in your your little text
there you suggested it you didn't say
you knew it happened you just said this
may be a thing
dig a Little Deeper bud
we're counting on you
if you can take down Steve Bannon by God
take down Steve Bannon do it don't just
sit there with wild accusations right
you can't get away with that
you can't make these suggestions and
then just let that be it no man
if you've got something
well put it this way as the airport say
if you see something say something
so I'm putting that on you Roger Stone
if you've got any evidence at all to
suggest that Steve Bannon may have been
involved in planning the capital riot in
inciting the capital Riot and calling
the people to storm the capital
please come forward hand it over to that
committee and maybe for once in your
life
you could be a hero not just to the
Republican dirty tricksters
but maybe to the American public as well
see I'm just trying to appeal to your
human side if you have one
Heaven only knows if you do but uh yeah
I'm all with you if you want to take
down Bannon just putting it out there
and finally speaking of the January 6
committee Alex Jones has decided to sue
the January 6 committee and of course uh
uh ATT to stop the release of his phone
records
to that committee
now his argument
a little interesting let's hear it here
um
it says quote in the lawsuit a
declaratory judgment that the subpoena
to Alex Jones and the subpoena to at T
serve no valid legislative purposes and
exceed the select committees and
congress's constitutional Authority in
violation of the separation of powers
principle contained in the United States
Constitution
now if he had stopped before you got to
the separation of powers
you actually had what's not considered
to be a terrible legal argument
the separation of powers has nothing to
do with what you're talking about though
so you kind of overstepped there but
let's get to this right the
Constitutional basis
for the House of Representatives a
committee in the House of
Representatives to carry out these
investigations believe it or not is that
included in the Constitution
no
no it's not
that's something a lot of people do not
know
but the Constitution does not say
specifically explicitly that the House
of Representatives gets to carry out
these investigations however precedent
tells us otherwise court cases Supreme
Court cases tell us otherwise because
the Supreme Court for several hundred
years now has interpreted the
Constitution to basically say that the
founders intended for Congress to have
this power
because you know all other duties that's
actually what they cite so the courts
have told us Congress does have this
Authority
even if it's not always for a specific
legislative purpose
and for the record the history Buffs out
there you may already know this this
goes back to 1795.
when Congress con conducted its first
investigatory action really
happened all throughout the 18th century
or excuse me the 19th century the 20th
century and of course all the way to
today and court cases all along the way
reaffirmed congress's authority to
actually do this
so if you were going by the strict
letter of the law in the U.S
Constitution This legal argument is
actually not that absurd
which you know a little disappointing
but when you look at past Court
precedent when you look at the precedent
that Congress itself is set the powers
that they have won in these court cases
then they absolutely have the authority
to do this even if
it's not for an explicitly legislative
purpose now that may be the only thing
because that's still considered a very
legal or very gray area in the legal
world
that may may do something to move the
needle a little bit
but I seriously doubt it
um courts have already ruled obviously
in this particular matter not
necessarily with Alex Jones but in Trump
trying to claim executive privilege from
other committees also saying you can't
have my my financial documents because
it's not for a legislative purpose
courts have said yeah uh we don't care
that doesn't matter it doesn't have to
be
again constitutions iffy on this it's
going to depend on what kind of Judge it
goes up against but of course Alex Jones
if he was in communication
with these individuals inside the White
House on the day of the riot obviously
would be a person of interest which
would make it a valid subpoena if of
course Congress does have the authority
to even conduct these investigations
which is why as I continuously say the
committee needs to turn their documents
and everything they have over to a
special prosecutor and let the doj take
it from here you avoid questions like
this you avoid some issues
everybody's a winner we got some great
content coming up for you in the bonus
show I'm Farren cousins been sitting in
for David Pacman today you can find me
on Twitter Facebook Instagram at fair
and balanced rofpodcast.com thanks for
watching and I'll see you tomorrow